we've done punch cards already but we've
not really talked about tape input
solutions for computers I think the
thing to make very clear to people of
course is that this really goes back a
long way end of xix beginning of the
20th century because it can't come out a
computer industry it came out of the
Telegraph industry there they were you
know sending telegraph signals initially
by Morse but then somebody came along as
they looked rather than using Morse why
not have a fixed length code of well I
would have called it a 5-bit code but
that's what we would call it nowadays it
is it's a 5-bit code tooth power 5 is 32
there were 32 possible characters that
you could signal in five bits don't get
confused by this small running set of
holes down the middle those are the
sprocket holes and whether you're
reading or punching this tape you've got
to have some motive force you've gotta
go to drive it forwards as it were and
typically on mechanical systems a tooth
wheel will engage in the so called
sprocket holes and we'll pull the thing
forward but a completely separate set of
circular punches below will every time
you press a key put owl pattern as you
can see going horizontally into this
tape so this particular code in five
bits was originally invented by a
Frenchman called Bordeaux and it was
very successful although he didn't
actually tie it into a proper typewriter
he had his own I think five key funny
weird thing that you wiggled about a bit
in order to make the hole punching his
work gentlemen call Murray had the idea
why not link this to a proper typewriter
so every time he type an a it punches
out the five hole code for a he worked
for a telegraph company as well he said
look if we're going to be punching holes
to correspond to characters every time
you punch one of these big holes it
wears out that hole punch on your
machine how about
that for the most common characters in
English and in sensible European
languages we will punch the smallest
number of holes that will reduce the
wear on the punching mechanism so yes
when you look at the board Elmarie code
ya Bordeaux's code as adapted by Murray
you will find that the letter e uses
precisely one hole going horizontally
and T uses one hole I think many of you
know it goes something like actor Oh Wyn
shrew do in English is the frequency of
the letters ETA oh I am oh yes you
weren't taught at two wings for a blue
horse roll do when you were all Shawn
you missed out on a true telecoms
education obviously didn't los have a
similar thing about making he did he
tried his best but he he made a few
mistakes because he went to a printing
shop a printers shop and there were
almost right the population of how many
E's are there in that box and so on but
yes you try very hard to do that Morse
was a variable length code he is one dot
whereas Zed is something like three
dashes in the dot this was determined to
keep things simple by saying we're going
to have a fixed length code it'll be
five bits for every character
it's just that in modern parlance those
big holes represent a 1 in the code and
if you read across on any single
character and you see a space where
there could be a hole but there isn't
then that represents a zero so if it's
possible to focus in on this topmost
punch character it's something like
let's read it from left to right it's
one zero one ignore the sprocket holes
zero one I hope that's the right way
around to read it but you get the idea
the big holes represent ones in the code
the places where they could be a hole
but isn't represent zeros so reading
across any one of these you get a five
hole code and in special places you even
find that the one with all five holes by
is a special reserved symbol I can't see
any of them on here now but that's used
for so-called change of shift shift on
the keyboard it is very much like that
it's got the usual problem okay you've
got zero 231 you've got 32 combinations
that's scarcely enough to do the
alphabet by the tummy have added 26
alphabetic characters 10 numbers that's
36 gone and you've only got 32
well what's the story and the answer is
very similar to a typewriter what you do
is you say okay we're going to have to
have reserved codes which say if you hit
this code it means change the state of
your machine to expect basically numbers
and punctuation and then when you fed up
we're doing numbers and punctuation you
change back into the default letter mode
again so whenever you're in so-called
letter shift which is a default you can
always change into figure shift and when
you done your fours and your fives and
you're commas and you want to come out a
finger shift you hit the change to
letter shift code which is fine it works
very well so long as you coherently read
the tape in the correct order from start
to finish
it can be a bit of a brute if you put
tape on in the middle of itself thinking
you'll be in letter shift code but
you're not the characters are assuming
it's figure shift and the whole thing
comes out looking like a mess until
fortunately sometimes it might
resynchronize this is what I did my
initial programming on for the Mercury
computer owned by the University of
London it was five whole paper tape the
punch machines the teletypes as we call
them I think were made by a firm called
creed and yeah this is what you got out
you punch your program up like this you
took it off to you tape reader in the
computer room and it read it in in five
whole code and that was your program all
your data or whatever the other thing of
course to be aware of is that yes we
know now that it's got to be a
mechanical process to punch these holes
but what about reading them
but men the retaping reader in the
computer room well again it would
perhaps if it was slow happy sprocket
driven down the small holes to drive it
forward but you then have a clear choice
how are you going to sense these holes
here on every horizontal row that
represent the ones in your character
you've obviously got to sense them and
all of the places where you try and
sense and you don't succeed well that's
a zero
well pretty obviously there's two
answers you could do it mechanically and
slow take readers did just that
you put the thing in and went chug chug
chug along the sprocket holes and you
can almost see the sensor rods coming up
from underneath trying to gently push
through the holes and if they got
through the hole then of course have
made a contact and they sense the
character as being one zero one zero
zero one whatever but of course if you
wanted real fast luxury you sensed photo
electrically and that's another thing
you've got to remember
Einstein won the Nobel Prize for
explaining the photoelectric effect in
1905 so it's been known about for a long
long time and it did not take
electronics engineers long to be able to
make small or large photoelectric cells
certainly when I copied these out when I
was at London University and put them
through the tape copying option at the
side of my typewriter course you could
plug it in there make sure you have
plenty of blank tape then you could
start the tape reader and believe his
own heart it would go chug-chug like
this every time it sensed a character
would type it out on a sheet of paper
for me but behind the reader it was
chanting out a copy and punching holes
to make an exact replica of this so that
was a truly electromechanical solution
it was going pretty slowly and you've
got all these sort of tabs accumulating
on the floor and things like this
waiting for the commas that hanging
chads yeah has a such a thing where the
could be but it's less of a problem for
some reason I think in paper tape but
yeah that wasn't
I mean Murray was right there was a
problem with where you know you if you
were doing frequent tape punching you
really had to make sure
those were absolutely correctly bunched
so there we are then I mean that's five
old paper tape technology by the time
you get to seven and 8-bit ASCII you
don't want to be mucking about with
vigor shift and letter shift and of
course that was the thing about the
initially 700 128 ASCII options and
later of course the extension to a 8
hole working and the ISO alphabet 256
and all that is you needed obviously
seven whole table rate old tables and
that is preserving all 5 the 16-bit
microprocessors could not use the
bandwidth that was available in the
memory that people put in these machines
so you spent your money you bought some
bandwidth and then you're coupling this
to a processor that couldn't use that
basic resource and this just struck us
as wrong